it completely
took us all by shock that's Corey
Richards talking to ABC station ktvx
last month to publicize her book are you
with me published in March she says she
wrote the book with her children to help
them cope with the death of their father
Eric it's just comforting to them to
know that you know they're not living
this life alone like Dad is still here
it's just in a different way but now
she's been charged with her husband's
murder shocking friends like Linda King
in her western Utah neighborhood they're
was so beautiful
I guess it wasn't Corey Richards is
charged with felony first degree
aggravated murder she's also charged
with three counts of possession of the
drug GHB which in large doses can be
lethal it makes me sick to my stomach to
think about that